I'm sure he's going to use every tool
available to him in terms of as well if
he passes however because he's playing
in stahma hawk who plays hockey he might
actually not as well specifically
because of the matchup we're gonna show
our age a little big here and let y'all
know it's on like Donkey Kong you know
some of the kids playing I get that
reference and it's okay because you're
beating all of us and taking our money
all the time anyway so it's just let us
have that another classic shirt on their
stage you're going across the school
guys been around for a very very long
time around these parts versus West
battle by the way
ow I mean it is Britain's webs oh sorry
I got hypnotized no no I feel you it's
Lee he's the savior of humanity after
all you know he state he saved your your
mind don't start you know I'll go on for
hours you already know I will be yeah
I'm not a hundred percent sure Feynman
is going to play as well because
tomahawk plays hockey yeah okay I hear
Siegfried and the reason being is he
feels like talking is one of the few
characters in the entirety of the game
okay that actually gives trying to get
Sandman up out of here as he continues
his turn no friendship nothing but a
handshake for camaraderie and respect at
the game and it's on now fighting
face-to-face is versus weight doesn't
roll for throw the second thing is off
the sandbag keep it right in front
watching that position and gonna get the
the jumping K right there very generous
hitbox in that situation in stock you
can roll her way in through the side
door nice duck it's almost like he saw
that coming entirely right back cat
shoot ya know tekwar duck for the
Sandman though he's gone okay just
interrupts the break attack right there
nose splash on the wall but he's still
able to catch him second and he was able
to get one hit on the wall by the way
and and it's really important to
recognize that two hits are left on the
wall because if Siegfried gets a wall
combo here it's automatic rings yeah
yeah for sure because they're
specifically few minutes sounds like
Christmas it's gonna follow things up I
got a dive out of there try to stay away
from the wall if
kid and talk to pull off oh okay the
mix-up here 50/50 I'm gets the up kicks
okay Dark Legacy is on deck though she's
got to watch that yeah that's why he
went to the low and that's why he went
to the low again they should kill them
yeah beautiful stuff there from tomahawk
gonna come in with the faint jumping in
into the hippie jump lowest classic I
mean you know you also gotta check the
the Dark Legacy bubble activation Ryan
lows are gonna feed out the activator
he's gonna test them I want you to do it
like let's get rid of it forget it
yeah well I mean you tested him right
there with a kk and was able to duck
under it pretty well and oh you should
not tuck that one I will tell you what
is that the ring out hey there it is
Omaha gotta love it guarantee and I
gotta talk about you know this is
definitely one of the stronger your
commentator slash players
I gotta call it out real good at going
up top yeah getting this done right
there there's a lot of power on deck for
Sandman right now and I mean he's
fighting a hack deficit he's got dark
legacy on deck but that so much oh he
was able to tuck under the grab right
now and okay wow yeah is not what you
want to see night nation off of
something that tomahawk actually did to
him
hey man what the pack turned you knew
what was coming right it's only one
option for this like I want to secure
this round and get it right now
going into the final around with two
floors yes time on your hands
life is able to control off this one and
I mean there's so much meter on deck
football players and I'm just so supply
that Sandman hasn't gone through it
there's busy right now and the [ __ ] yeah
Auto GI it with the base hold you just
walks away from the ledge she doesn't
want to push too hard the Dark Legacy is
active so charged as well yeah but this
time tomahawk had a lot to give dos a
mistake while and steal oh man the
running goes for the slag is the
entirety oh my god no he does not
survive at all she doesn't have any
health KP I don't see nothing there I
don't see nothing either in the form of
I don't have the answers for you with
tomahawk the magic picks will use like
you know what if I'm gonna die right
here he's gonna be in my hands I'm not
gonna block or take a mixup at this
situation I got knocked down saint man
probably thought it was over and didn't
see the prompt but when I go losing
alright let's take it to the skies I
worked once before why not do it again I
definitely think he really he was sure
that it wasn't over like he reacted but
he just was not ready to wake up kick
specifically he was probably trying to
look for a role trying to get that extra
damage no times and now look tomahawk
now as oppressive and offensive as he
possibly can be
yeah have the walls back now so one
opportunity to
and look he did that combo specifically
to save the wall because he wants the
possibility of you never to get the ring
out because he's in Dark Legacy that was
a lethal hit and look at the damage
oh god tomahawk again just so impressive
on a pixel now with Sandman's turn to
answer it and they all might be a
punishing Tom on the clutch master in
this situation no pixel no problem
definitely really good awareness on the
defense right there was able to block
the low and that got him to around he's
coming back in right now okay there's
the low hit the mix-up after is really
prevalent though that gives me those
plus frames and no just straight
disrespect from Sandman yeah a bee fly
back to back we a four to be able to
catch the staff with no dice no
Catherine's here hurts out with pit
bulls there you go get that lethal b6
become so strong and so charged party
really good move but prior to that right
like it's a it's incredibly fast it's
pretty good trainer up nice block right
there though
[Music]
get the wall using the aerial control
say that not what to do definitely
freaked out situation if you saw last
time it gave one of the double kids back
to back now quietly GBAS blocks does
have dark latency on decks where the
damage ability is explosive with the
lethal hits however you just gonna get
hit low and tomahawks not wanting to see
the ability of Sandman what's he gonna
doing low light situations guy cuz I'm
not dealing with a close at the door as
quickly as humanly possible okay bro
this is the first one that will deduct I
think yeah he tried to get away from it
but there's the possession hold for
throw keep him along the wall I had the
fear of God in me to see that's big
damage I mean you know counter hit you
want to react just an extra I wasn't too
sure but I didn't know it was counter
hit so I knew it was gonna get the extra
damage I just wasn't sure if it was
gonna kill but there it is
tomahawk you know I mean he's proven
himself to be strong but prior to this
he's making it happen here
unfortunately the Sandman is going to go
home that's gonna be into that as well I
think you still have at least three or
four or five more says it's something up
Connelly I could point all the plows I
have a voice of reason
all right not the power of it you can
believe in all that but the voice of
reason will always trump the power of
reason until otherwise anyway we gotta
losers top eight qualifier match coming